early on in cyberpunk 2077 there's a
series of side quests that has you
tracking down
rogue taxis run by faulty ai you have to
talk one of the taxis down from suicide
as it contemplates driving off a bridge
while another needs to be brute force
into behaving
and a third is an obvious reference to a
famous video game ai that manipulates
you as you chase it down
it's one of the best minor quest lines
in the game an intriguing and
surprisingly human sub-story that
rewards you with lots of much-needed
cash to boot
it's also an excuse to send you to every
corner of night city and it's a clever
introduction to all the areas you
haven't yet been
i spent a lot of my play time following
side quest threads like this one
excited about the premise and hoping to
find something as interesting or fun or
rewarding at the end
in many cases i did but now after
finishing the main story i can't see how
most of those activities fit into the
overall narrative or the character i was
playing that whole time
the main story doesn't even gel with
itself can't stop digging knights
city like any other
cyberpunk 2077 draws heavily from its
source material with everything from the
world itself
to the life and death of johnny
silverhand coming from its pen and paper
inspiration
but unlike in a tabletop rpg you aren't
playing a role of your own creation in
cyberpunk 2077
you're playing v and this is v story not
yours
i often felt like i was role playing two
different characters
one v for the side quests and one more
limited v for the main story
that's mostly because the main story
puts you on a clock it's not literally
on a timer but it is
very urgent in the way that rpg stories
often are
and has the same pitfalls as a result it
feels weird to do throwaway fun stuff
when you have a serious
ever present threat to attend to and in
v's case it just doesn't make sense to
dally
you have more freedom to play the
character you really want to during side
activities but main story v has clearly
defined priorities
it's first place or no place dex cost
isn't a factor
classic i'd expect nothing less from
eager
supplement respect i often couldn't find
the character i'd been developing via
side quests when i returned to the main
plot
not in how i'd been shaping her
personality as she reacted to events
nor in the hacker i built as she was
forced into more traditional boss fights
i knew from the outset that i wanted to
play as a hacker so i sped through the
character creator
gave my v points and intellect and cool
for hacking and stealth respectively
and started the game i had picked the
nomad life path out of the three total
options because it was the only one that
positioned v
as an outsider tonight city i figured
that i didn't know night city yet as a
newcomer to the game so why should v
from what i can tell that life path
choice didn't affect more than the way
the game starts and some dialogue
options throughout
and possibly some minor side quests now
that i've finished the story i'm much
more curious about the corpo life path
in which
v used to work as an antagonist
corporation arasaka and how that fits
into what i played
but it doesn't feel like a majorly
important decision in my experience
the real rpg core is in your five main
stats which are further split into two
or three different skill trees each
providing various benefits to combat
stealth hacking and so on
using these sub skills will passively
level them up and give you additional
benefits ensuring you grow according to
how you play in addition to how you
actively invest points as you level up
the parent skills mainly govern what
dialogue options you can use and what
kinds of doors you're able to open at
least in the moment to moment they
otherwise provide
minor stab boosts because of this i
tended to invest skills based on my
curiosity in conversations or to access
areas i wanted to explore
because the sub skills have their own
leveling and points system i found i
could freely invest overall skill points
without sacrificing my hacking goals at
least when it came to the traditional
rpg progression
hacking into computers and transferring
money to your account is one thing
it only requires enough points in the
intellect parent skill just like how
body allows you to open certain doors
on the other hand quick hacking which
allows you to manipulate cameras
turrets enemies and more in hostile
scenarios requires a lot of cyberware
investment
specifically you need a good cyber deck
which determines how many different
quick hacks you can equip
that has enough ram so you can use ones
that demand more memory
cyberware in general is not cheap on top
of that an early story mission is gated
by a significant sum of money so i had
to do a lot of grinding before i could
afford a proper cyber deck that made my
quick hacks truly effective
until then i felt like i had to use guns
a lot more than i wanted to which didn't
fit with how i initially built my
character
i didn't mind the guns overall though
while it's not on par with dedicated
first person shooters the gun play is
decent
it's a little clunky even after tweaking
my sensitivity settings but the aim
assist does the heavy lifting
once i got a good cyber deck and
equipped better quick hacks combat
really picked up for me
i had a quick hack that reset an enemy's
optics because pretty much everyone in
night city has cyberware in place of
organic eyes i used a quick hack that
reset an enemy's
optics and temporarily blinded them
which allowed me to sneak past
i was able to shut off entire camera
systems easily and set turrets to
friendly mode so they wouldn't shoot me
on site
i approached most encounters like a
puzzle i'd hack into camera systems to
see how many enemies i'm dealing with
then i'd figure out who to distract and
in which direction so i could move from
room to room undetected
if that didn't work i at least knew i
could jam their weapons or shock their
systems from afar
when i found my rhythm and found the
cash i really enjoyed quick hacking as
an alternative approach to combat and it
was always satisfying to get in
steal a bunch of money off some
computers and get out without being
spotted
because i was so focused on this aspect
of my character and saving money to
invest in it
i didn't end up spending much time on
other approaches
i got the mantis blades which are
cyberware swords that spring out of your
arms
so late in the game that i barely used
them other cyberware upgrades like a leg
modification that gives you a double
jump were so expensive that i'd have to
opt to take side jobs just to afford
them
though this becomes easier later in the
game when those gigs have bigger payouts
in fact most nice things in night city
are prohibitively expensive and i found
that money was often the only obstacle
when it came to progression
granted i was playing cyberpunk on a
tight deadline so i couldn't spend much
time doing odd jobs
but there is a ridiculous amount of
stuff to buy and seemingly endless
money-making jobs to take on
there's even a whole section in your
quest journal dedicated to all the cars
people have offered to sell you
though you start the game with a car and
i got multiple free vehicles for
completing side quests so i never bought
a car and couldn't find a reason to
that's emblematic of the world of
cyberpunk 2077
it is so full of things to buy to do to
see and yet so much of it doesn't feel
essential
night city is massive and while you can
fast travel from specific points you'll
often need to walk or drive a bit to
your destination
i started to compare prices from one
ripper dock to the next
they're how you upgrade your oh so
expensive cyberware but i stopped after
the third because i didn't want to drag
myself across the city all day
i went clothing shopping only once for
the same reason and i had managed to
loot more than one cute outfit off of
corpses anyway there's even an
entire crafting and item upgrade menu
that i never actually
needed to use given that i was regularly
looting better gear and items off my
numerous enemies
at least in my playthrough i had no
reason to engage with these systems at
all
night city is beautiful and vile the
architecture is often stunning and some
of my favorite sections of the game were
when i drove from one district to the
next
radio turned up taking in all the neon
lights and monolithic mega buildings
piercing the sky
then i get out of the car and hear one
of the oft repeated advertisements
blaring out under the street and quickly
snap out of the referee of driving
there's one ad that's just a man making
a long exaggerated orgasm sound that
tended to pierce through any
conversation i was having
[Music]
all pleasure from all booze provides 330
of recommended daily volume the ads are
one of many many aesthetic choices in
cyberpunk 2077 that are grading with no
real point
there's one ad in particular that was
the topic of much discussion pre-release
it features a feminine person with a
giant exaggerated veiny erection in
their leotard and advertises a drink
called chromanticore with the tagline
mix it up it is everywhere and while the
purpose of it
may be to show what a sex-obsessed
superficial exploitative place night
city is
there's nothing in the main story or any
of the side quests i did that gives it
even that much context
i found just one message on one of the
many computers i logged into that
commented on how low brow night city
culture is
the result is that there's a
fetishization of trans people at every
turn
in a game with only one very minor trans
character that i found at least
and with a very limited and binary
character creator
not a lot of ways to play as an
authentically trans character yourself
i found and read tons of text blogs
scoured people's private messages
listened to radio and tv programs and
random npc conversations
and i struggled to find justifications
for many of cyberpunk's more
questionable and superficial
world-building choices
it's a world where megacorporations rule
people's lives where inequality runs
rampant and where violence is a fact of
life
but i found very little in the main
story side quests or
environment that explores any of these
topics it's a tough world and a hard one
to exist in by design
but with no apparent purpose and context
to that experience
all you're left with is the
unpleasantness there are instances where
the game does do more with an initially
superficial choice but these threads are
often dropped quickly
for example in the pen and paper game
the voodoo boys were a group of mostly
white men who used quote-unquote voodoo
stereotypes to scare people
in 2077 they're a group of haitian
people displaced by natural disaster
by my interpretation one caused by
climate change at one point in the main
story you can ask a voodoo boys member
what the name's about given they don't
actually do anything associated with
quote-unquote voodoo
he tells you to ask the people that call
them that and refuses to tell you what
they call themselves
there's a seed of an interesting idea
here the labels given to the other
diaspora the trauma of losing your home
but none of this is ever explored again
in the main story as i played it nor in
any of the many side quests i played
either i didn't find another opportunity
to interact with the voodoo boys at all
there's so much to cover that i can't
possibly touch on everything but my
experience is that there's aspects of
the game that feel lost in translation
invoking cultures that aren't adequately
explored or contextualized characters in
one sidequest use the word ofrenda as if
it means funeral when it's actually a
particular kind of altar primarily for
day of the dead
it's unclear to me if this is a
translation issue or an overall
misunderstanding of mexican customs
since you do put together an altar
during the event that's being called
the afrenda it's not that cyberpunk
always gets everything wrong in its
incorporation of a variety of cultures
and backgrounds but that the world
is so big and unruly that i never knew
what i would find around any corner or
if i'd understand what the intent behind
it was i just grew to accept that
whatever i did find
at least in terms of setting in world
building would likely be superficial
that's the case for the world overall in
its background characters anyway
you meet a lot of people in night city
many of whom
die in your wake like you're some kind
of curse while others just call from
time to time with a job for you to do
the few that don't die and have proper
arcs make up v's friends and love
interests and these are the characters
that rightfully stand out
okay let's test this my favorite
character though is judy alvarez an
earnest
hot-tempered beautifully human character
with the best arc in the game
she edits brain dances which are kind of
like vr movies where you can acutely
feel the recorder's emotions
and they're often used for porn judy is
an incredibly gifted bd editor and she's
also a member of the moxes a gang of sex
workers that look out for one another
judy's story unfolds thanks to her
fierce and endless desire to fight for
her friends which leads to some of the
most interesting quests in the game
and some of the only ones that give you
the ability to properly fight back
against such a bleak exploitative world
the final section of judy's arc was my
favorite in the entire game
it's a quiet respite from the lights and
sounds of the city an
intimate look into the soul of her
character and provided you meet the
requirements contains the only sex scene
i saw that didn't make me want to die on
the spot
unlike you i don't put myself out there
zapper doubles and filth in some ways
night city never changes
legendary rocker boy johnny silverhand
is with you for the vast majority of the
game
showing up in pretty much every mission
to try to influence your decisions
make snide remarks or just kick back on
a bed in the background while you talk
to someone
his relationship with v is often
antagonistic sometimes playfully so and
other times outright hostile johnny is
simply put
an [ __ ] it's a testament to keanu
reeve's performance that i actually
liked him
he treated his friends badly and women
worse he's the kind of guy who gets away
with far too much and based on what i
learned about him throughout the game
i'm surprised he died at the hands of
adam smasher rather than by choking on
his own vomit after a bender
reeves is somehow able to make all of
this interesting and kind of charming
rather than extremely off-putting
for the most part johnny is a
well-written character and that i was
always curious what he had to say and
how he interpreted the situations we
were in
i was never quite sure if his advice was
any good or if his opinions had any
merit but i wanted to hear him out every
time
it's reeves delivery of these lines
which often involve johnny chastising
you for something or other that really
sells the lovable jerk vibe that i would
normally find
overplayed the push and pull of johnny's
opinions and your own adds a lot of
color to even run-of-the-mill missions
at one point i didn't heed johnny's
condescending warnings and accepted a
deal from a character who ended up
tricking me which also resulted in a lot
of people dying
another time i pursued a side quest only
because he practically begged me to do
it saying it was the most interesting
thing we'd stumbled upon in a long time
and it did end up being unlike anything
else in the game the dynamic is
compelling and left me on my toes
always wondering if i should listen to
johnny or follow my initial instincts
it's not up to you though is it let's go
i'm not sure if there were necessarily
any completely right or wrong choices in
a lot of those missions but johnny's
presence and the ambiguity it brings is
supposed to have an effect on v's psyche
for better or worse
it's a factor of the circumstances that
put him in v's head in the first place
that johnny could affect my decision
making as well as how i interpreted each
interaction is a clever way to convey
that
aside from character highlights side
quests are far and away the best part of
the game
like the rogue taxi one i mentioned at
the beginning of this review there are
quite a few
clever interesting goofy and sad side
quests that i really enjoyed
on a gameplay level they often provide a
nice change of pace from the more combat
focused main story
sometimes you just talk to people while
a more involved one has you doing favors
for johnny since he's you know
technically dead
one especially intriguing side quest had
me playing detective
investigating a mysterious break-in at
the apartment of a night city mayoral
candidate
mechanically it's a simple open world
use your ability to highlight clues
gimmick but what follows is a
fascinating and kind of creepy look at
night city corruption
gaslighting and whether it's better to
tell someone the truth if it means it
could get them killed
conversely i also did a really silly
quest that involved a clown man with a
grenade for a nose that had no point but
was delightful in a weird way
side quests amounted to around 35 hours
of my total play time and they were what
propelled me through
while not everyone lands there are some
that feel essential in a way that very
little else in the game does
these include judy's story arc and the
taxi excursion as well as a much shorter
story about a depressed man who lives in
v's apartment building
even on the tight review deadline i kept
finding myself seeking out just one more
side quest before bed just because i was
eager to see what i would find
all that said when i finished the game i
felt empty all the friends i had made
what i had learned about johnny the way
i developed my v as a character much of
it didn't seem to matter
making friends in a lonely sad city
doesn't affect the urgency of v's main
quest
and it doesn't seem to affect her
priorities related to it discovering a
police-sponsored murder cover-up or the
depths of corporate control of night
city life doesn't seem to change
v's ambitions to be remembered as a
legendary night city merc
falling in love didn't even give my v
what she wanted
i don't quite understand the ending i
got but it made me sad
it didn't reflect the v i felt i
developed one who helped her friends and
followed her curiosity
worst of all i have no idea what
cyberpunk 2077 is even trying to say
there's an overall theme of identity
that's dashed by the distance between
the v
you actually play and the v you get in
the end otherwise
i couldn't tell you what cyberpunk is
trying to do with its beautifully
grotesque world
i got a lot out of the side quests and
some of the characters but i got nothing
out of the overall story
it's all right matteo i was waiting for
this one
but you'd have to watch out for negative
energy fields it also bears a mention
cyberpunk 2077 is phenomenally buggy
she's even my ass b thank you
i played a pre-release build on pc that
was updated during the review period
and there's a day one patch planned as
well but the scale of technical issues
is just
too large to reasonably expect immediate
fixes
i encountered some kind of bug on every
mission i went on
for more common funnier ones like
characters randomly t-posing
to several complete crashes i didn't
notice much of an improvement after the
update either
in a very late game very important fight
the game froze on me
not once but twice i ended up taking a
break out of frustration before
attempting and finally succeeding the
third time
these bugs more than any game i've
played in years
took me out of the experience often i
was playing on a gaming laptop well
above the minimum specs announced for
cyberpunk 2077
while another gamespot player
experienced the same severity and
frequency of bugs though no hard crashes
on an even higher end desktop pc your
mileage may vary but in our experience
the bugs are obtrusive and substantial
across the board
often forcing us to reload saves or exit
the game entirely
it's really hard to get into a world you
constantly have to leave
but then it's hard to get into cyberpunk
2077's world in general
so much of it is superficial set
dressing and there's so much happening
all around you
like ads going off at all times
gunfights breaking out in the streets
texts coming in about cars you'll never
buy
that a lot of the game feels superfluous
the side quests and the characters they
showcase are the shining beacon through
the neon soaked bleakness of night city
and they give you room to explore the
best the core rpg mechanics have to
offer
these are what carried me through an
otherwise disappointing experience